mise en place par l' agence activity
l'association et qualys et la mairie de
la verrière
une quinzaine d'employés en contrat
d'insertion confectionne des masques il
travaille répartis sur une dizaine de
machines actuellement de l'avant 16
personnes et ce qui se passe c'est
qu'ils apprennent à faire de la couture
affaires de masques il ya des personnes
qui sont qualifiés et puis à d'autres
personnes qui n'ont jamais jamais
pratiqué donc ils apprennent le
maniement de la machine et à coudre la
salle khobar du scarabée a été choisie
pour héberger cette initiative
pendant les quatre mois de l'opération
c'est effectivement la ville qui met à
disposition cette salle du scarabée
il ya également la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines qui a financé les machines il
ya des particuliers qui font des dons de
tissus
c'est 100% coton pour ceux qui veulent
faire des dons on a vraiment besoin
d'eux depuis l'instauration il y a deux
semaines le groupe a déjà fabriqué plus
de 150 masque avec une majorité de
tissus recyclés
les employés ont pour la plupart été
formés sur place à la couture quand même
en fait
max tous les jours canac et kuzi bien
irak et après la course
moi je faisais pas du tout de couture
avant j'ai vraiment découvert ici
au début on touche un peu à tout pour
pour apprendre et ensuite on va plutôt
se spécialiser ses versets de les
personnes qui ont plus de mal à coups de
fond vont passer pour faire leur passage
je veux qu'on découvre et comme ça après
on va avoir une production plus optimale
le chantier d'insertion se tient
jusqu'en janvier date à laquelle les dix
mille masques devraient être achevés et
distribués aux citoyens de la commune de
la verrière